THE MBA. I KNOW YOU LOVE
HOOPS. DO YOU LOVE TALKING
ABOUT THE LAKERS AS MUCH AS
YOU PROBABLY HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THEM THESE DAYS
. YEAH, NO COMPLAINTS ON THE
LAKE OR TALK. I MEAN LISTEN,
IF YOU'RE IN THE MEDIA AS YOU
CAN RELATE TO THE BIGGER THE
FAN BASE, THE MORE FOLKS ARE
ENJOYING THE COMMENTARY AND
THE COVERAGE. SO YEAH, NO
PROBLEMS THERE GOT TO PLAY
THE HITS SOMETIMES WELL, LET
ME ASK YOU THEN ABOUT THE
LAKERS AND THE CONCERN HERE
WITH THE INJURY SITUATION.
OBVIOUSLY ANTHONY DAVIS.
BEEN OUT FOR A WHILE.
LEBRON'S GOING TO BE OUT
PROBABLY FOR AROUND A MONTH
OR SO. DO YOU ANTICIPATE THEM
MAKING A MOVE MAY BE TRYING
TO ADD A LITTLE SHOOTING HERE
THURSDAY?
I MEAN, I'M SURE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ACTIVE. THEY'RE
PRETTY LIMITED THOUGH AND
WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO DO.
THEY'RE PRETTY CLOSE TO THEIR
HARD CAP. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
KINDS OF PIECES THAT I THINK
THAT THEY'RE WILLING TO MOVE
OUT IN TERMS OF THEIR BIGGER
PICTURE THAT'S IN PLAY THE
YOU KNOW, THE TITLE DEFENSE
AND THE IDEA THAT ONCE LEBRON
AND AD GET BACK, YOU KNOW,
YOU CAN'T BE LOSING A DENNIS
SCHRODER MONTREZL HARRELL
ANYBODY LIKE THAT WHO MIGHT
NOT BE ABLE TO HELP CARRY YOU
NOW BUT
GOING TO COME IN HANDY AND
YOU HOPE I'LL BE PART OF THAT
CHAMPIONSHIP PICTURE ONCE
YOU'RE WHOLE AGAIN. SO, YOU
KNOW, YOU HEAR CONSISTENTLY
THEM TIED TO RIM PROTECTION IS
IS JAVALE MCGEE GONNA COME
BACK SOMEBODY LIKE THAT. YOU
KNOW NOW OF COURSE THEY COULD
USE, YOU KNOW PLAYERS WITH
KIND OF THE MORE VERSATILE
SKILL SET BECAUSE OF THE
INJURY STUFF, BUT I'D BE
SURPRISED IF THEY REALLY
FOUND ANY REAL LEGITIMATE
ANSWERS ON THAT FRONT AND THE
NEXT TWO DAYS. MAYBE SOMEBODY
I CAN ANDRE DRUMMOND COULD
END UP YOU KNOW IT. OH SURE.
YEAH. YEAH ANDRES ONE THAT
YOU KNOW, HE'S GONNA
CERTAINLY BE SOUGHT AFTER
QUITE A BIT IF THAT BUYOUT
ENDS UP HAPPENING AND IT
PROBABLY WILL I MEAN, I THINK
HE'S AROUND 30 MILLION WITH
HIS CALVES DEAL. SO THE BIG
WOULD BE MY FOCUS WITH THEM
AND THEN JUST KIND OF TRYING
TO TREAD WATER. YOU KNOW, I
HAVE THIS THEORY EVERYBODY'S
WORRIED THAT THEY HAVE TO YOU
KNOW, THEY FALL DOWN TO A
SEVEN OR AN EIGHT SEED AND
THEY HAVE TO DO THE WHOLE
PLAY IN DEAL TO GET INTO THE
TOURNAMENT. I ALMOST
I THINK THAT IF I'M LEBRON
THAT MAKES THE STORY EVEN
BETTER IF THEY WERE ABLE TO
WIN AGAIN, RIGHT SURE
. THEY I MEAN IF THEY'RE ABLE
TO WIN AGAIN A HUNDRED
PERCENT, I YOU KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW I MEAN, YEAH GREAT STORY
LINE, BUT AND FAR BE IT FROM
ME TO EVER QUESTION THE GUY
WHO KEEPS SHOWING US THAT THE
BAD IDEA BUT 36 YEAR-OLD
LEBRON COMING OFF A SERIOUS
ANKLE INJURY, YOU KNOW HAVING
TO THEN TAKE OUT AN ELITE
WESTERN CONFERENCE.
AND STEAM IN THE FIRST ROUND,
YOU KNOW AND FIGHT YOUR WAY
KIND OF UP THE CHAMPIONSHIP
MOUNTAIN FROM THERE TO ME.
THE WEST IS LOADED ENOUGH AND
THERE'S ENOUGH PARITY THAT
YOU KNOW, IF YOU WERE ASKING
ME TO BET YOU KNOW ON THE
LAKERS OR THE FIELD AND THAT
SCENARIO, I'D PROBABLY BE
BETTING ON THE FIELD THEY
SO TRADE DEADLINE COMING UP
THURSDAY, AARON GORDON BEING
SHOPPED. KYLE LOWRY
COULD BE ON THE MOVE FROM
TORONTO MARVIN BAGLEY AS YOU
ALLUDED TO AND WHEN YOU
ARTICLES THE KINGS HAVE NOT
FOUND ANY ANY TAKERS FOR HIM
YET. WHAT ARE A COUPLE OF
MOVES OR TRADES THAT YOU
EXPECT TO HAPPEN HERE BEFORE
THE TRADE DEADLINE?
WELL, THE GORDON SITUATION
HAS BEEN A FOCAL POINT OF MY
WE WROTE ABOUT THE SITUATION
WITH BOSTON THE OTHER DAY AND
AND THE KIND OF REVELATION
THAT AARON ASKED FOR A TRADE
LAST MONTH, YOU KNOW FORMALLY
AND I THINK THAT WILL HAPPEN.
I THINK RIGHT NOW I WOULD
FEEL HANDICAPPED BOSTON AS
THE LEADER BUT DENVER IS
DEFINITELY IN THE MIX AND
DEFINITELY WANT AARON AND
IT'S KIND OF THAT. YOU KNOW
NOW IT'S THAT GAME THE CAT
AND MOUSE GAME OF
THERE'S STILL TIME ON THE
CLOCK AND LIKE THE NUGGETS
FOR INSTANCE DON'T WANT TO BE
TOO DESPERATE. THEY DON'T
FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO MAKE A
MOVE. THE CELTICS HAVE A TON
OF PRESSURE ON THEM, YOU KNOW
PLAYING 500 BASKETBALL WHEN
YOU HAD TWO ALL-STARS WHO ARE
USED TO BEING IN THE
CONFERENCE FINALS IS NOT A
GOOD EQUATION. AND SO I'M
CURIOUS TO SEE WHERE THAT
GOES. I THINK IF AARON BOOBS
IT'S GOING TO BE ONE OF THOSE
TWO TEAMS, YOU KNOW LOWRY
AND I THOUGHT KYLE WAS GOING
TO STAY PUT BECAUSE HIS MONEY
IS SO HARD TO MATCH 30
MILLION DOLLARS ON AN EXPIRED.
DEAL, BUT YOU KNOW THERE IS A
LOT OF NOISE ABOUT PHILLY AND
AND MIAMI AND AND THE
CLIPPERS HAVE BEEN INTERESTED,
BUT I DON'T THEY, YOU KNOW,
THEY CAN'T GET THEIR MONEY
WISE. SO, YOU KNOW KYLE'S
ANOTHER ONE AND STAYING IN
TORONTO OR TAMPA TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC NORMAN POWELL IS
ANOTHER GUY WITH A TON OF
TEAMS CHASING HIM AND AND I
THINK IS GOING TO BE A NICE
ADDITION TO THE PROBABLY A
CONTENDER. SO I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A BUNCH OF LIKE,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF SECOND AND
THIRD TIER GUYS PROBABLY GET
MOVING.
MOVED AS YOU KNOW, THEN IT'S
NOT A SUPERSTAR TRADE
DEADLINE SEASON, YOU KNOW
AFTER THE HARDENED TRADE WENT
DOWN. THERE'S REALLY NOBODY
ELSE OUT THERE OF THAT
SPEAKING OF SUPERSTARS
BROOKLYN THE TEAM TO BEAT I
MEAN IS IT ONCE THEY'RE
HEALTHY AND ONCE THEY HAVE
ALL THE PARTS THERE G SEE
I DON'T KNOW. I MEAN I KIND
OF LOVE HOW WIDE OPEN IT IS
BECAUSE YEAH, THERE'S MOMENTS
WHEN YOU SAY YEAH, HOW DO YOU
BEAT THAT TRIO? WELL FOR ONE
THAT TRIO HAS BARELY BEEN
TOGETHER. NOW YOU GOT GUY
READ MISSING GAMES FOR FAMILY
REASONS, YOU KNOW AND HAVING
ANOTHER ABSENCE THE DURANT
INJURY OBVIOUSLY IS A PROBLEM
YOU FEEL FOR KEVIN MAN. HE
SPENT SO MUCH TIME ON THE
SIDELINES LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS AND NOW TO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH IT AGAIN, YOU KNOW,
AND EVEN JAMES HAS BEEN
BANGED UP SO, YOU KNOW, I'M
NOT SOLD ON THEM.
AS THE TITLE FRONT-RUNNER
HERE'S THE FUNNY PART TO ME
IS LIKE WE'RE GUILTY IN THE
MEDIA OF BEING VERY NARRATIVE
DRIVEN AND SO MILWAUKEE JUMPS
OUT BECAUSE IT'S LIKE I FEEL
LIKE IN THE MEDIA. WE HAVEN'T
OFFICIALLY DECIDED THAT THAT
YANIS CAN'T BE THE
BACK-TO-BACK-TO-BACK NDP
JUST BECAUSE THEY FELL SHORT
IN THE PLAYOFFS, BUT HE YOU
KNOW HAD BEEN PLAYING WELL
BEFORE HE GOT A LITTLE BIT
BANGED UP AS WELL. BUT YOU
KNOW, THE BUCKS ARE A TEAM
I THINK WE'RE SLEEPING ON
AND AND JANA SAID PARTICULAR
IN HIS MVP CANDIDACY, BUT I
MEAN THERE'S YOU KNOW, THE
UTAH CLIPPERS LAKERS ALL THE
WAY DOWN THE LINE STILI. I
REALLY I PROBABLY HAVE
RECENCY BIAS A LITTLE BIT,
I FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW MORE
THAN IN PAST YEARS. IT'S JUST
REALLY WIDE OPEN, BUT
THE MOST COMPELLING TEAM FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF WE LOVE
SUPER TEAMS AND AND
MONITORING WHETHER OR NOT
THEY CAN MAXIMIZE THEIR
INCREDIBLE TALENT. AND SO I'M
HOPING IN THAT VEIN THAT THE
NETS ARE HEALTHY.
WHEN THE PLAYOFF TIME COMES
AROUND BECAUSE I REALLY WANT
TO SEE IF THEY CAN HAVE
CHEMISTRY AND IF THEY CAN GO
OUT AND BE THE TEAM THAT THAT
WE THINK THEY MIGHT BE ABLE
TO BE. YEAH, SO DO I I MEAN
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE COLLECTION
OF TALENT THEY HAVE THEIR IN
MAKING OF MAXIMIZING
POTENTIAL I FEEL LIKE LONZO
BALLS IS CLOSER TO MAXIMIZING
POTENTIAL AND HE'S IN LINE TO
GET A MUCH BIGGER PAYDAY THAN
WE ANTICIPATED THAT HE WOULD
BE GETTING A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO. I SAW YESTERDAY OR THE
DAY BEFORE WHERE MICHAEL
THOMPSON KLAY THOMPSON'S DAD
WHO CALLS LAKERS GAMES ON THE
RADIO SAID, I'D LOVE TO SEE
LONZO END UP IN GOLDEN STATE.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU COULD
I COULD YEAH IT IS. THERE'S
LIKE A LEVELING OUT OF DE
LONGUEVILLE MARKET HAPPENING
WHERE YOU KNOW PHASE ONE WAS
THE INCREDIBLY OVERHYPED
OPENING WITH LEVAR, YOU KNOW
TELLING THE WORLD THAT LANZA
WAS GOING TO BE THE NEXT
COMING OF OF YOU KNOW, STEVE
NASH COMBINED WITH WITH, YOU
KNOW, GARY PAYTON AND CHRIS
PAUL AND ALL THE BEST POINT
GUARDS OF ALL TIME MAGIC
JOHNSON CHIEF AMONG THEM AND
AND AND THAT WAS JUST TOO
MUCH AND TO LAUNCH A COULDN'T
UP TO THAT. BUT NOW THAT
IN CLOSER TO FREE AGENCY AND
YOU KNOW THAT HE HAS
DEVELOPED AND REALLY HIS
DEFENSIVE SIDE OF THE BALL
AND HIS ABILITY TO TO PLAY
BOTH GUARD POSITION HAS MADE
HIM A NICE FIT AND FOR A LOT
OF TEAMS AND THAT HAS A LOT
TO DO WITH ALL THE INTEREST
BECAUSE IF IT'S ATLANTA,
RIGHT AND THEY LOOK AT IT AND
THEY GO YEAH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK LONZO CAN MAYBE PLAY
WITH TREY IF IT'S THE
WARRIORS, YOU KNOW, AND YOU
HAVE A HEALTHY KLAY THOMPSON
WITH STAFF AND ALONZO HAS A
THREE-GUARD SET. I MEAN, THAT
WOULD BE PRETTY DANGEROUS.
AND UNTIL TO LAUNCH HIS
CREDIT, HE'S CHECKING A LOT
MORE BOXES AS A PLAYER THAT I
THINK, YOU KNOW COMING OUT OF
YOU KNOW IN THE BEGINNING IT
WAS ALL ABOUT HIS PLAYMAKING
AND THAT WAS IT HE AND HIS
CAMP WANT AND THE KIND OF
EXPECT TO BE GETTING AROUND
20 MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
FREE AGENCY. THAT'S KIND OF
THE THE WORD AMONG TEAMS
THAT ARE INTERESTED. AND SO,
YOU KNOW, THAT'S KIND OF THE
UNOFFICIAL PRICE TAG, YOU
HAVE TO CONSIDER BUT BUT YEAH,
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW THE
WARRIORS HAVE THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT DRAFT PICKED
THAT IS THE MOST VALUABLE
ASSET IN THE LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I DOUBT
THEY'D BE WILLING TO GIVE UP
SOMETHING LIKE THAT FOR LONZO,
BUT IF THEY WERE ABLE TO GET
THEM, I THINK HE HE CERTAINLY
WOULD WOULD TAKE THEM TO A
NEW LEVEL. YEAH. HE'S
AVERAGING CAREER HIGHS IN
POINTS IN THREE-POINT FIELD
GOAL PERCENTAGE BECOME A MUCH
BETTER SHOOTER SINCE HE
ENTERED THE LEAGUE SPEAKING
OF THE DRAFT. OBVIOUSLY.
YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING THE NCAA
TOURNAMENT LIKE THE REST OF
US WHOSE POPPED WHO HAVE YOU
NOTICED THAT THAT'S GOING TO
A DIFFERENCE MAKER, AND I GOT
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU BROTHER.
I'M JUST GOING TO OWN IT. I
HAVE NOT BEEN DIVING IN. I'VE
BEEN IN TRADE MODE. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT IS. YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, WE HAD A GOOD TIME ON
MY PODCAST YESTERDAY TODAY.
JOKING ABOUT KADE CUNNINGHAM.
ONE OF MY CO-HOST ANTHONY
SLATER IS AN OKLAHOMA STATE
ALUM AND AND HE WAS DISHING A
LITTLE BIT OF CAKE COUNTING
HIM SLANDER AND SAYING THAT
HE THOUGHT HE MIGHT BE A
LITTLE OVER HYPED. SO THAT'S
KIND OF BEEN THE EXTENT OF
STA A FOCUS. I JUST KNOW
THAT I MEAN,
THROUGH THE NBA LENS, YOU
KNOW THE IDEA THAT YOU COULD
HAVE, YOU KNOW IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIVE
FRANCHISE CHANGING TYPE
PLAYERS IS YOU KNOW, IT'S
COLORING DECISIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW THAT THAT
PART IS ALWAYS BEEN REALLY
INTERESTING TO ME BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, YOU GOT TEAMS IN REAL
TIME DECIDING. ARE WE GOING
TO TANK ARE WE GOING TO GO
FOR IT AND TRY TO SNEAK INTO
THE PLAYOFFS? WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO? AND THAT
CALCULUS IS TIED, YOU KNOW TO
TO NOT ONLY THE DRAFT BUT
THEN NOW IN REAL TIME WITH
THE TOURNAMENT, YOU KNOW,
LIKE YOU SAID WHO'S TOP AND
WHO'S NOT SO, YOU KNOW THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE A RIPPLE EFFECT,
YOU KNOW, BUT ADMITTEDLY I
PROBABLY SHOULD START DIVING
A LITTLE BIT MORE AND
WATCHING THE ACTION RIGHT NOW.
WELL, PROBABLY NOT A FAIR
QUESTION FOR YOU WITH THE
TRADE DEADLINE COMING UP. SO
BELIEVE ME. I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND LITTLE BUSY DURING
FOOTBALL SEASON. IT'S
CERTAINLY ALL ABOUT FOOTBALL
FOR ME AND I'M NOT WATCHING
AS MUCH COLLEGE AS I DO AND I
FELL NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT. THE
KATE CUNNINGHAM STUFF IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE I THINK
HE'S A NICE PLAYER BUT MAN
HE HAS REALLY BEEN IMPRESSIVE
FROM WHAT I HAVE SEEN.
THE TOURNAMENT AND THE OTHER
THING THAT'S REALLY
FASCINATING FROM THE
ATLANTIC IS WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THE JEELY AND THE
PLAYERS NOW WHO ARE CHOOSING
TO GO TO THE G-LEAGUE INSTEAD
OF OVERSEAS OR INSTEAD OF
OVERSEAS OR INSTEAD OF
COLLEGE FOR A YEAR AND THIS
NEW PROGRAM THAT THEY HAVE
WHERE THEY CAN PAY HIM HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEY CAN
PAY HIM HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS AND THEY CAN SIGN
SHOE DEALS AND THEY'RE GOING
TO BE DEVELOPED AND PLAY
AGAINST SOLID COMPETITION.
HOW HAS THAT BEEN LOOKED AT
THIS YEAR? IT HAS IT BEEN
ALREADY DESIGNATED AS A
SUCCESS.
I THINK THE ANSWER IS YES,
BUT THEN THE KIND OF ASTER IS
THAT THE PANDEMIC MADE
THINGS. I MEAN IT MADE THINGS
HARD ON EVERYBODY BUT IT
REALLY IMPACTED THE JEELY
QUITE A BIT NOW, THEY DID
PULL OFF THE G-LEAGUE BUBBLE
AND KIND OF MADE THE BEST OF
A CHALLENGING SITUATION, BUT
BY AND LARGE 100% THE
REPUTATION OF THE G-LEAGUE
AND PREVIOUSLY KNOWN AS THE
D-LEAGUE HAS CHANGED IN THE
KIND OF WAY THAT IT IT'S A
WHOLE LOT CLOSER TO BEING A
BASEBALL STYLE.
MINOR LEAGUE SYSTEM NOW THAN
EVER BECAUSE IT IT'S FUNNY. I
MEAN, I'VE COVERED THE LEAGUE
ROUGHLY FOUR, I GUESS 17
YEARS NOW AND YOU KNOW IN THE
BEGINNING WHEN A PLAYER GOT
ASSIGNED TO THE D-LEAGUE, I
MEAN, IT WAS LIKE GETTING A
SIGN FROM A PROTEIN BACK TO A
COLLEGE TEAM. I MEAN YOU WERE,
YOU KNOW GUYS WOULD PROBABLY,
YOU KNOW MORE LIKELY TO JUST
QUIT AND TRY SOME OTHER
AVENUE THAN THEY WERE TO TAKE
THAT ASSIGNMENT AND FEEL
OKAY ABOUT IT. IT WAS NOT THE
TEAM IT WAS SOMETHING
OF BURN WITH THEIR NBA TEAM.
I MEAN YOU EVEN HEAR STORIES
ABOUT GUYS SAYING COULD YOU
PUT ME ON ASSIGNMENT DOWN
WITH THE D-LEAGUE TEAM? LET
ME ACTUALLY GO AND PROVEN AND
YOU KNOW, THERE'S NOT THAT
THE COMPLEX ABOUT THAT PATH.
SO YEAH, IT'S A LEGITIMATE
THING AND THEY YOU KNOW, THEY
WERE SMART ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT MONEY MAKES THE WORLD GO
AROUND AND YOU GOT TO
INCENTIVIZE THESE GUYS TO GET
PAID REAL BASKETBALL MONEY AS
OPPOSED TO THE YOU KNOW, I
MEAN IN THE BEGINNING IT WAS
LIKE $25,000 ANNUAL STIPENDS
RIGHT TO GO PLAY.
HIM IN THE D-LEAGUE AND IT'S
IT'S ON A WHOLE DIFFERENT
LEVEL. NOW. THEY HAVE THAT
IGNITE TEAM NOW AND YOU LOOK
AT SOME OF THESE MOCK DRAFTS
AND YOU HAVE JALEN GREEN IS
GOING TO BE A TOP FOUR TOP
FIVE PICK JONATHAN COMMINGLED.
I BELIEVE I'M SAYING THAT
CORRECTLY AND BOTH THOSE GUYS
IN THE J-LEAGUE, YOU KNOW IS
TEENAGERS. SO CERTAINLY THAT
AGAIN YOU GOT THE COACHING
ASPECT TO YOU KNOW, WITH WITH
BRIAN SHAW PEOPLE LIKE THAT
BEING PART OF IT ADDS
CREDIBILITY, YOU KNOW FORMER
HEAD COACH HAS SO YEAH. IT'S
REALLY EVERY LISTEN ALL
AROUND THE LEAGUE THEY
THEY'RE THE KIND OF A
COMPREHENSIVE ROBUST SYSTEM
NOW THAN THEY WERE EVEN 10 15
YEARS AGO. YES, CERTAINLY.
COME A LONG WAY SAM A MIX
SENIOR NBA RIDER FROM THE
ATHLETIC SAM. THANK YOU SO
YOU GOT A DAMN. THANKS, MAN.